die Insel Kuba steht seit mehr als 60
Jahren unter den Joch der castrodiktatur
ein Zeitraum in dem die Insel zu einem
der ärmsten Länder Amerikas geworden ist
Schätzungen zur Folge hat dies dazu
geführt dass in den letzten 25 Jahren
erst eine Million Menschen die Insel
verlassen haben und das bei einer
Gesamtbevölkerung von knapp über 11
Millionen Einwohnern wir haben es also
mit einem riesigen Exodus zu tun der
sich keineswegs verlangsamt sondern
immer mehr Anfahrt gewählt allein in den
ersten 9 Monaten des Jahres 2020 sind
fast 200.000 Kubaner von der Insel in
die Vereinigten Staaten geflohen und das
ist ein historischer Höchststand der
jeden vorherigen Zeitraum übertrifft
[Musik]
so viel also die aktuelle Lage auf Kuba
über die wir hier auf visualpolitik noch
bald ausführlicher sprechen werden
tatsache ist dass die castrodiktatur
trotz dieser komplexen Situation im
allgemeinen keine schlechte Presse hatte
ja praktisch jede akzeptiert das Gruber
eine Diktatur ist aber eine Diktatur
über die es schon immer jede Menge
Mythen gab die dazu beigetragen haben
dass das Bild des castroismus beschädigt
wird und so unglaublich ist auch klingen
mag in Lateinamerika war wieder Castro
einer der beliebtesten Politiker des 20
Jahrhunderts ja wir wissen dass wir
katastrophile Gegner hatte aber eben
auch sehr viele Unterstützer und viele
Anhänger eine der effektivsten
Kommunikationsstrategien des kubanischen
Regimes ist die regelmäßige Entsendung
von Hunderten und Tausenden von Ärzten
in unruhige Länder ja kubanische Ärzte
sind wirklich sehr berühmt geworden von
Italien über Jamaika bist wenn es zu Ela
haben sie alle Arten von Krisen und
Katastrophen auf der ganzen Welt
durchleben aber wusstet ihr dass diese
gesundheitsmissionen den Regime
Millionen von Dollar einbringen meine
liebe Zuschauer in diesem Video werdet
ihr die ganze Geschichte erfahren über
eines der besten Geschäfte die Havanna
in den letzten 50 Jahren zustande
gebracht hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im Laufe der Jahre ist die kubanische
Medizin zu einer der großen Legenden des
castorischens geworden ich bin mir
sicher dass fast alle von euch diese
Geschichte schon gehört haben die
Legende eines durch die teuflische
us-blockade bestraften Volk ist dass es
trotz allem und trotz aller Widrigkeiten
geschafft hat einen Gesundheitssystem
aufzubauen dass an der Spitze der Welt
steht ja schade dass die wahre
Geschichte ganz anders aussieht vor
allem wenn ihr ein Durchschnittsbürger
Kuhbar sein solltet ja Kuba wendet einen
großen Teil seiner Ressourcen für das
Gesundheitssystem auf es wird auf etwa
11 % des BIP geschätzt angeblich hat
dies zu relativ guten Statistiken in den
Bereichen wieder durchschnittlichen
Lebenserwartung unter
Kindersterblichkeit geführt es gibt
jedoch ein Problem diese Oxford Studie
die er auf dem Bildschirm sieht liegt
nahe dass diese Statistiken manipuliert
werden und dass sie auch durch die
eigene wirtschaftliche Situation verzert
sind es gibt zum Beispiel so gut wie
keine Autos und ohne Autos gibt es auch
keine tödlichen Verkehrsunfälle außerdem
gibt es auf Kuban nicht nur eigene
Gesundheitssystem sondern zwei
verschiedene Systeme die quasi
nebeneinander stehen
auf der einen Seite gibt es das
Gesundheitssystem für Ausländer und die
kubanische Elite ein System dessen Ziel
ist ist durch
medizintourismus-insland zu holen wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist das
natürlich das modernste System der Insel
und es ist für normale Kubaner ohne
erreichbar diese haben nur Zugang zu
einem ganz anderen Gesundheitssystem
eines System in dem die Infrastruktur
brückelt und es in allen möglichen
Dingen malt um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben wenn ein Patient in ein
öffentliches Krankenhaus muss er seine
eigene Bettwäsche Handtücher
Lebensmittel und Seife mitbringen die
Bilder sprechen für sich es ist eine
ganz andere Geschichte als die die
normalerweise erzählt wird und eine die
eine ganz andere Realität erklärt
14 mai 2022 Kuba stellt einen schweren
Mangel an Medikamenten für alle Arten
von Krankheiten fest unbestreitbar ist
jedoch das Gruber einen so guten Ruf
genießt dass Freunde des Regimes nicht
zögern zu Behandlung eines medizinischen
Problems auf die Insel zu reisen und es
handelt sich wirklich um die wahre
Kräfte im März 2017 Evo Morales erwartet
seine Reise nach Kuba um sich eine
Operation zu unterziehen
november 2012 scherwest reist nach Kuba
um sich einer Sonderbehandlung zu
unterziehen dass wenn es solanische
Parlament er möchte ich den Präsidenten
auf unbestimmte Zeit abwesend zu sein
ich weiß nicht wie ich mich bei diesem
Land bedanken soll sagte florenzia
Kirchner bei ihren Abschied aus Kuba die
Tochter der Vizepräsidentin Christina
Fernandes und es Verstorbenen ehemaligen
Präsidenten nestore Kirchner beschrieb
auf ihrem Instagram Account kurz ihren
Aufenthalt und ihre Behandlung in den
karibischen Land bevor sie nach
Argentinien zurückkehrte April 20 wo ist
Daniel Ortega die lange Abwesenheit des
decaraguanischen Präsidenten inmitten
der coronavirus-pandemie schürt Gerüchte
über seinen Gesundheitszustand Dora
marathelles die in den 1980er Jahren
Mitglied von ortegaskabinett verhält es
für sehr wahrscheinlich dass er auf Kuba
ist auf die ein oder andere Weise ist
das kubanische Gesundheitswesen zu einer
der wichtigsten Instrumente der
softpower der Insel geworden eine
riesige Marketingkampagne für die
Revolution ich bin mir sicher ihr
erinnert euch alle an Nachrichten wie
diese
22 März 2020 Kuba schickt
sanitätsbrigaden nach Italien und
Lateinamerika um dem Corona-Virus zu
begegnen
29 März 2020 kubanische Ärzte gehen nach
Andorra ihr zweites europäisches Ziel
gegen kovid 19 15 Juni 2020 rubanische
Ärzte wurden länger als erwartet in
Mexiko bleiben wenn telefonkovic 19
ansteigen im September 200 Gastro sogar
die Schaffung eines internationalen
Kontingents von Ärzten an die auf
Katastrophen und schwere Epidemien
spezialisiert sind um die Vereinigten
Staaten nach dem Hurricane Katrina in
New Orleans zu unterstützen diese Gruppe
wurde Henry Reef international medical
Brigade genannt später setzte die
Brigade ihre Arbeit fort und wurde von
der Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO für
ihren Einsatz in Afrika bei der
Einwendung des Ebola Ausbruchs gelobt
und die Frage ist was steckt wirklich
hinter all diesen Missionen ist alles
wirklich so sauber und von humanitären
Motiven durchdrungen wie es auf den
ersten Blick erscheint in diesem Video
werden wir herausfinden was wirklich in
der all diesen Vorgänge steckt ja wir
haben es mit der Kehrseite von Kubas
besten diplomatischen Instrument zu tun
also aufgepasst
Gesundheit Diplomatie und revolutionäre
Solidarität
1963 fand der sogenannte sandsvorstadt
ein Krieg zwischen Algerien und Marokko
in den Kuba in einem geopolitischen
Kontext Eingriff der Inselstaat nahm
damals an verschiedenen Kriegen
zugunsten der mit der Sowjetunion
verbündeten Staaten teil und bei dieser
Gelegenheit geschah etwas ganz
Besonderes der Mangel an Ärzten in der
Region veranlasst durch die Welt Castro
zu einer Strategie Brigaden von
Gesundheitsexperten zu entsenden um den
Mangel zu beheben um den Soldaten und
Opfer des Konflikts zu helfen es
handelte sich um die Generalprobe für
eine Politik die immer massiver häufige
und systematischer zum Einsatz kommen
sollte ein kleiner Hinweis am Rande es
mag euch vielleicht überraschen aber
zwischen 1960 und 1990 führten die
kubanischen Streitkräfte mindestens acht
globalen militärische Interventionen
durch fünf davon in Afrika Algerien
Syrien Kongo Angola und Äthiopien und
die restlichen in Mittelamerika und der
Karibik sagen wir einfach dass die
kubanische Armee wird
Ära zu einer Expeditionsgruppe im
Dienste der kommunistischen Revolution
wurde doch der zunehmende Misserfolg
diese Expeditionen drängte cast dazu
einen anderen vielleicht freundlicheren
Weg der Einflussnahme auf Drittländer zu
finden und so kam es das darf den
Erfahrungen in Algerien die merkwürdige
Strategie der medizinischen Brigaden zu
köcheln begann
und seit diesem ersten Versuch im Jahr
1963 haben nach Angaben des Regimes und
600.000 kubanische gesundheitsfachkräfte
in mehr als 160 Ländern medizinische
Dienste geleistet sogar bis heute in
diesem Moment sind rund 30.000
kubanische Ärzte in 67 Ländern aktiv in
Einsatz wir sprechen hier von einem
wiege Öl funktionierenden System der
softpower sowohl logistisch als auch
wirtschaftlich vor allem wenn wir
bedenken dass Kuba diese Aktivitäten zu
einem riesigen Geschäft gemacht hat ja
ihr habt richtig gehört eine riesiges
und außerordentlich lukratives Geschäft
und wie dieses funktioniert werde dem
Ende dieses Videos genau verstehen bevor
wir loslegen möchte ich euch aber eine
kleine Empfehlung geben die äußerst
lukrativ für euer Wissen sein wird es
geht um einen jungen und knackigen Kanal
der ebenfalls von unseren
Produktionsteam herausgegeben wird cold
fusion.de
er wird euch bestimmt gefallen falls
euch spannendes Stories über Technik
Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft aber auch
über Gesellschaft und Politik
interessieren wenn ihr zum Beispiel
wissen wollt wie die Wissenschaft den
bisher als unaufhaltsam geltenden
Alterungsprozess des Menschen immer
weiter umkehren kann oder was genau
hinter der Twitter Übernahme durch Maske
steckt auf Call fusion.de erfahrt ihr
alle Hintergründe und Zusammenhänge
dieser Kanal deckt wirklich ein breites
Spektrum wissenswerter Themen ab in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video findet
ihr einen Link zu konfusion.de also
schaut mal rein und nun wieder ab in die
Karibik wo wir euch in alle Details des
medizinischen mega Business Kubas
Einbein werden
[Musik]
eine sehr profitables Geschäft für das
Regime
Kuba ist traditionell ein hermetisch
abgeriegeltes Land wenn es um die
Regierung geht das ist ein klassisches
Problem mit Diktaturen sie sind nicht
gerade die transparentesten Staatsformen
trotzdem sind seit dem Jahr 2000
bestimmte Methoden und Regeln für den
Aufbau und die Finanzierung
medizinischer Programme auf der ganzen
Welt bekannt geworden die ehrlich gesagt
nicht mit den grundlegenden Rechten
eines jeden Arbeitnehmers vereinbar sind
und etwas später im März 2010 er liest
die kubanische Regierung den Beschluss
Nummer 168 es geht um die disziplinären
Regeln für kubanische Zivilarbeiter die
im Ausland in Kollaborationen arbeiten
[Musik]
dieses Dokument ist seit einer
Veröffentlichung äußerst umstritten oder
anderen wegen der Verstöße die es in
Bezug auf den Disziplin Zusammenhang mit
dem Ansehen und den sozialen Verhalten
der Beschäftigten festlegt diese
Verordnung sanktioniert zum Beispiel
Verhaltensweisen wie die folgende das
heißt keine fragilisierung mit
nichtrevolutionären und
nichtkommunistischen Menschen und
natürlich keine Beziehungen auch keine
freundschaftlichen die nicht von den
Vorgesetzten genehmigt wurden
und das sind nur drei Beispiele für eine
lange sehr lange Liste von
disziplinarvorschriften die jeden Aspekt
des Lebens von medizinischen Personal im
Ausland akribisch und bis ins kleinste
Teil Regeln natürlich unterliegen alle
kubanischen Ärzte den kubanischen
Strafgesetzbuch vor allem wenn sie sich
von dem kapitalistischen
Annehmlichkeiten verführen lassen diese
in den Ländern indem sie ihre Dienste
anbieten finden können wenn ein Beamter
oder Angestellter der mit der Erfüllung
eines Auftrags in einem anderen Land
betraut ist und diesen aufgibt oder
nachdem er erfüllt hat oder zu
irgendeinem Zeitpunkt aufgefordert wurde
zurückzukehren sich ausdrücklich oder
stillschweigend dies zu tun nächsten
Schritt mit einer Freiheitsstrafe von 3
bis 8 Jahren bestraft Artikel 176.1 ist
kubanischen Strafgesetzbuchs tja und ich
weiß nicht ob ein so strikter Codex mit
einer so weitreichenden Kontrolle über
das Leben der Arbeiter zu dem Bild von
Freiwilligen ersten passt die kommen um
uneigennützig Hilfe zu leisten und die
Frage ist wird es eine Gegenreaktion
geben
[Musik]
nun die Wahrheit ist dass die
Sonderberichterstatter der Vereinten
Nationen für Menschenhandel und
zeitgenössische Formen der Sklaverei
2019 einen Teil ihrer Arbeit Kuba
gewidmet haben sie haben jenen
Wirtschaftskreislauf unter die Lupe
genommen der dazu dient Millionen von
Dollars aus diesen Missionen zu sammeln
die im Lichte diese Informationen nicht
länger als allzu humanitär angesehen
werden können unter anderem forderten
die berichterstatte die kubanische
Regierung auf zu den Vorwürfen Stellung
zu nehmen und Maßnahmen zu ergreifen die
kubanische Regierung erhält von den
Regierungen in der Gastländer einen
Geldbetrag und zahlt den Arbeitnehmern
einen Teil dieser Gelder in Ländern in
denen die Regierung des Gastlandes den
kubanischen Arbeitnehmer direkt bezahlt
musste kubanische Arbeitnehmer einen
Prozentsatz eines Lohnes an die
kubanische Regierung zurückzahlen der
von 75 auf bis zu 90% seines Monatslohns
ansteigt
Erstatter für zeitgenössische Formen der
Sklaverei 2019 das heißt Sie können
nicht nur keine unerlaubten Beziehungen
eingehen sich weigern zu arbeiten oder
sich in einem anderen Land niederlassen
mit seinem kubanisches Gesundheits
Personal wird auch nicht in einer Weise
bezahlt die ihre Arbeit entsprechen
würde
[Musik]
einen Bericht von Personal Defender
zufolge zahlte die mexikanische
Regierung für jeden der 585 kubanischen
Ärzte und für die Krankenschwestern die
in der mexikanischen Hauptstadt Dienst
tun 10.700 US-Dollar für drei Monate das
heißt ca 3.560 US-Dollar pro Monat und
das während Havanna ihnen nur 600
US-Dollar für drei Monate das heißt 200
$ pro Monat als Pixum im Land gehabt und
von diesen 10.000 700 $ für 3 Monate
sahen diese dann nur 600 $ für 3 Monate
das heißt nur 200 US-Dollar pro Monat
mit anderen Worten die kubanische
Regierung und schreibe dir und 90,4%
beste Betrag den sie für ihre erste
verlangte und gab ihnen einen Hungerlohn
von dem man in Mexiko nicht einmal ein
ständigen Lebensstandard haben kann
aber das ist noch nicht alles die
un-beamten verlangten auch Klarheit über
die Arbeitszeiten und Arbeitspläne zu
denen das Gesundheitspersonal gezwungen
wird
die Ärzte würden 48 Stunden pro Woche
arbeiten und zusätzlich 16 Stunden auf
ab Hof was zu einer Gesamtzeit von 64
Stunden pro Woche führt oft auch
samstags und sonntags die überzähligen
Arbeitsstunden verdeutlichen die
Ausbeutung der Arbeitskraft der
kubanischen Ärzte im Ausland ausgesetzt
sind
UN-Sonderberichterstatter für
zeitgenössische Formen der Sklaverei
2019 tja alles im Dienste der Revolution
oder besser gesagt der obersten Führung
der Revolution
und genau diese Bedingungen waren es die
das Europäische Parlament im Juni 2021
dazu brachte das kubanische medizinische
missionssystem zu verurteilen zum ersten
Mal wie es eine wichtige politische
Institution deutlich auf den wahren
Charakter der kubanischen Missionen hin
das Europäische Parlament verurteilt die
systematischen Menschen und
Arbeitsrechtsverletzungen die der
kubanische Staat gegen seinen
Gesundheitspersonal begehrtischen
Einsetzen ins Ausland geschickt wird
aber Moment mal denn das ist noch lange
nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange neben
der Ausbeutung von Arbeitskräften
diplomatischen Einfluss und softpower
verfolgenden gesundheitsmissionen
vielleicht noch ein anderes viel
fragwürdigeres Ziel und zwar nicht
weniger als indirekten Export ihrer
Revolution und was genau ist damit auf
sich hat erfahrt ihr jetzt also
aufgepasst
jenseits des Anscheins
bin zu Ela ist wahrscheinlich das Land
in dem kubanische gesundheitsmissionen
am häufigsten interveniert haben
hugo-persönlich machte dies zu einem
seiner zentralen Wahlkampfthemen bei den
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2012
[Musik]
es ist bekannt dass das Regime eine enge
Zusammenarbeit mit Kuba pflegte und
immer noch pflegt und dass wenn ihr zu
Ela auch im Austausch für kubanische
Ärzte Öl an das kubanische Regime
lieferte aber das ist noch nicht alles
es besteht der Verdacht und es gibt
deutlich Hinweise darauf dass diese
Brigaden in vielen Fällen auch als eine
Art Trojanisches Pferd fungierten danke
Ihnen und als Teil der medizinischen
Teams wurden viele Mitglieder des
kubanischen Geheimdienstes in Venezuela
eingeschleust und alle Schalthebel der
venezuelischen Gesellschaft zu
infiltrieren und das Regime zu
unterstützen
als die mexikanische Regierung von Reis
manuello pressuratore vor kurzem ein
ähnliches wenn auch viele kleineres
Programm für kubanische erste ankündigte
wurden deshalb Bedenken laut welche
Folgen dies haben könnte eben wegen der
sehr hohen Risikos dass der kubanische
Geheimnis versuchen könnte diese Mission
zu nutzen um dasselbe zu tun was er in
Venezuela getan hatte nämlich zu
versuchen das Land zu unterwandern zu
kontrollieren und die Flamme der
Revolution zu sehen oder zumindest das
Netzwerk für illegale Geschäfte zu
nutzen um Einfluss und den Wiesen zu
gewinnen da der Einsatz in diesem Fall
sehr klein ist scheint das tatsächlich
Risiko sehr begrenzt zu sein aber ich
meine was soll ich sagen das kubanische
Geheimdienste mehr oder mit der offenen
in einem Land operieren scheint nicht
die beste Nachricht der Welt zu sein
aber das ist eben die Kehrseite der
kubanischen gesundheitsmissionen diese
Missionen wurden nicht nur tausende
medizinische Mitarbeiter aus als wären
die sklavenarbeitern werden auch von
Regime als Instrument der weißen Macht
missbraucht und sogar Mechanismus um
andere Länder zu infiltrieren wenn ihr
also das nächste Mal Nachrichten über
diese Abkommen sieht solltet ihr gut
aufpassen denn dies ist eine der
wichtigsten Strategien zur Einflussnahme
und dem wiesenbeschaffung von der
einflussreichsten Diktaturen der letzten
Jahrzehnte und wie ihr als treue
visualpolitik Zuschauer bisher gut wisst
versucht Politik immer wieder hinter
wohltätig erscheinenden Fassaden
schreckliche Absichten zu verbergen aber
jetzt seid ihr an der Reihe kanntet ihr
diese globale Vorgehensweise Kubas was
haltet ihr von dieser Art von Strategie
wie immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion
zu diesem Thema schon richtig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht auch das
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
Like das mit euren Freunden keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit der er uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung dein
Video macht's gut bis bald
[Musik]